welcome to the Ann and Ashley Show. I'm Ann. I'm Ashley. And before we get started on today's
episode, please like and subscribe to these videos. And if you're on YouTube, you can hit the
little notification button so you are sure to never miss an episode on today's episode. We are going
to be talking about these devices here. These are called audio-visual entrainment devices and a few
weeks back we were lucky enough to have the developer of this technology come to the clinic and discuss
what this is and how it could be potentially beneficial to our patients here. So it was really
intriguing and after our conversation, we brought these into our clinic so they now are a therapy
that we offer here. But these devices are made so that you can do these therapies at home as well.
So they are available on our web store. So what is audio-visual entrainment? It utilizes these
cool glasses and then it also utilizes soundproof headphones. With this therapy, it comes with this
device here that you program the program that you want to run which has specific frequencies in it.
The glasses will then be emitting and flashing different, either a different color of light
or it's going to just be whatever program you have. It could be one side of the glasses or
both sides at once for simulation. You will have your eyes closed for this as well and then the headphones
will be having like a, it sounds like a heartbeat noise but it's going to have pulsing sounds coming
through those and it's going to help you so you can breathe deeply and kind of more calmly as well.
So you're going to just pick a non-disturbance environment for about 20 minutes or so
for this therapy and then yeah, you just relax. That's all you do. Your brain does work. It is also
meant to mirror the frequencies your brain does that are being stimulated with the device. So our brain
patterns is our norm and we get secondals patterns so it could be hard to break them and so the
training device then it kind of when it mirrors the frequencies like forces your brain to create these
new pathways and so on you bring like symptoms that you're experiencing can then go into a new path
and you break the norm that you have for the symptom, the pattern. Yeah, the pattern. Yeah, so
talking about different brainways and different patterns so we have four different brainwave
types. We have alpha, alpha, beta, delta and beta and normal, a normal healthy brain can kind of
switch between these different patterns depending on what the task is at hand so the sleeping
brainwave patterns are the alpha and the beta and then the you know focused attention test-taking
reading is the beta brainwave and so when we see kids who have ADD their brain is in the drainage
sleepy you know beta pattern where they're supposed to be taking the test and in the beta pattern
and so these devices have been you know proven there's research and studies and that's part of what
the developer that we spoke with he spent his career in the school systems tweaking and developing
the technology to specifically help these kids with ADD and autism and so he just based on their
responses and their patterns you know this is what he has put together and seen the studies that
back the improvement with this device so it was really intriguing to listen to him.
Yeah and you know there's different things that can stimulate the inappropriate brainwave patterns
whether it's something that has been in our environment that works both to whether it's a stressful
event a traumatic event whether there's a genetic piece so there's all these pieces that can disrupt
the normal brainwave pattern and again if you're stuck in a specific state then that's when you have
these symptoms so this device helps re-align those patterns so that your brain can jump from one
to the other and a healthy man. Yeah so some of the uses that are really researched with this
device would be like PTSD and anxiety depression insomnia mood disorders it has been studied with all
timers and dementia as well it can also help seniors with their balance and their mental clarity
it can help college students with learning and memory ADHD of course like you mentioned before
ADD and then the researcher also worked with a lot of autistic children when he was working in the
schools so the testimonials for that were really far and beyond what you can imagine so really good
studies under the autistic part as well. You also mentioned the mental healthy side the traumatic
disorders too. Yeah so he talked a lot about okay so when we experience trauma it's stored in
her bodies and this can be you know trauma that you remember or trauma that maybe something happened
when you were a baby in a stroller maybe all of a sudden the dog started barking and as a baby you
know that trigger or that memory and so as an adult you don't know why but you don't like dogs so
that's you know not like hugely impactful in life maybe but you just don't even know why you don't
like dogs and you know so what he was saying is you know for some of these traumatic experiences
when you go to a psychologist or psychiatrist and you do the talk therapy which is hugely beneficial
but for some people maybe bring some of those traumatic experiences to cognition is maybe not for
everyone maybe that's why some people don't go they don't want to relive those experiences so this
is a way to help help those people deal with those traumatic events because it just allows the body to
work the trauma out naturally through the nervous system still through this treatment your body is
resetting and able to release those traumatic events without bringing it to cognition so I think
that that can be helpful for so many people as well it's very powerful and you can do it in the
comfort of your own home which I think is huge for compliance you know people don't always have
the time in the day or it takes effort to go make enough appointment or something so to be able to
have this in your home and do it 20 minutes a day whatever it fits in your day which could be
equivalent to four hours of sleep right which is super cool yeah he said that he doesn't give
very much sleep but he uses this and so 20 minutes of this can be equivalent to flora where's
sleep and it can tap into your subconscious mind and just really put your whole body at that
relaxation that resting state right which is where you heal and so obviously we are a cancer clinic
most of our patients have cancer and autoimmune disease and so they're stuck in that stressful fight
or flat mode and our bodies don't heal well in that mode we meet people in the rest of
just in heal nervous system and so this helps you get there which allows your body to heal from cancer
heal from autoimmune disease heal from you know these other issues that yeah that people experience
just these little affect disorder I think you mentioned that here we are heading into the winter
months where I already heal it you know starting to get dark earlier and oh I just get the blues
and that has to do with melatonin production you know it can disrupt sleep and then it's the
cycle of events and so this can help with season life and pain to contain and a state of pain your
brain then is kind of shut down because you're so focused on the pain so getting your brain to
get in that restful state and hopefully the pain management can be alleviated as well right so
really cool I feel like every single person in my family yeah or that I know can benefit from this
so we're really excited to offer this in yeah and I get to our patients so yeah it is now our turn
to go do this and you go to sleep yes so that's it for today folks
Ashley and I are going to take off if you need any help with nutrition or genetics you can
call the clinic or if you have questions about the device the first consults always free
share this with your friends I'm sure you can think of plenty of people that need this device
in their life as well so yeah off we go brain and treatment see you next time